I don't know if you're aware I'm sure
you are though that you uh you you've
kind of caused the sensation on tick
tock
[Music]
have you seen any of these Tick Tock
videos do you have a favorite what do
you make of this movement people are so
so supportive and ready for this song no
it's amazing it's so exciting I've um
I'm a tick tocker now so I've been
watching uh all these incredible
Creative Tech talks and um yeah it's so
weird the songs it's just a chorus
that's out there so I can't wait to hear
the song please check out the song it's
it's a wild song it's it's a theater
show in one song
um and I'm so proud of it it's time for
my uh villain era I think yeah time to
get sexy it's definitely time to get
sexy I love it talk to me what do you
think it is that fans are going nuts for
about this I mean they are they are like
you said it's just about 19 20 seconds
been released but people already lined
up dying to have this what is it what is
what do you do to the folks oh my God I
have no idea that's music that's the
beauty of music I'm not in control of
that
um I make music write songs throw them
out in the air and hope that it touches
people so I'm very happy when it does
recently spoke about feeling revitalized
having this new Creative Energy talk on
that a little bit I'm interested oh my
gosh I think after covid everyone's
feeling
hungry to be around people again and see
people so I'm definitely feeling that
but I've had a transitional three years
of my life you know I've I've uh I've
turned 30.
um I think I know what I want to say now
I know who I am a bit more
um and I'm ready to have some fun really
I'm ready to have some fun with my music
and my job and and uh enjoy seeing
people again I want to talk these
Guinness World Records real quick how
cool is this most consecutive weeks in
the UK Top 10 album chart and the first
James Bond theme to reach number one in
the UK I mean congratulations you you're
doing tremendous work well weird though
right think about those James Bond songs
why did they not get to number one we
have Madonna we have Goldfinger oh my
gosh you know so um but I think that
Billy eilish has now gone to number one
and everything so I'm not alone and and
everyone's celebrating everyone now
what can fans most look forward to about
Unholy
the music video unbelievable the live
performances the spirit of the song is
just it gets better you know I've had it
in my ears now for a year and I'm still
not sick of it so I really hope that
people enjoy it the way that I am I love
it
[Music]
big night right we're honoring Barbara
and Michael let's talk about why are
they so deserving of this honor tonight
oh my gosh I mean I got to work with
them in 2000 I think it was 16 or like
yeah 2016. we're on Specter and um
they're just amazing I just saw Barbara
now like just beautiful beautiful people
kind so good at what they do and um
icons really
yeah yeah now let's talk about you
working with them your musical ability
and bond LED you to an Oscar Dare I ask
where do you keep your Oscar and what do
you remember most about receiving it oh
my gosh
um I keep it in my house in London
um it's a very weird thing to look at
um and what do I remember I remember the
hangover was very intense the next day
but I just remember having a it was a
whirlwind night absolute Whirlwind night
and um yeah I'm just very proud still
and to be a part of this Legacy
foreign